20:19 was a great year for movies
whether you bought tickets to see a
raunchy tween starring comedy or a
nuanced familiar drama d it felt like
that was a movie for everyone here are
the very best films of 2019 Rocket Man
is not a traditional biopic it's instead
aims to capture the life of the
legendary Elton John through a deft
blending of facts and fantasy
it's a bold gambit that somehow works
swimmingly thanks in large part to a
brilliantly performance from Taron
Egerton
Chicago readers Lea Pickett opined that
the fantasy conceit is part of what made
the film work so well she wrote this
fantastical take is undoubtedly how the
unconventional artists at its center
wanted it to be the story we shuffles
reality especially time and facts and
the film is more enjoyable for it many
critics were complimentary of adjutants
performance but Quad City Times Linda
cook summed it up best with a sweet line
I hope you don't mind that I put down in
words how wonderful life is when Elton
John's music and this movie are in the
world I never told you how much I need
you no fans waited four years for the
ninth film from Quentin Tarantino and as
usual the master delivered a singular
and amazing piece of cinema once upon a
time in Hollywood is Tarantino's
portrait of the swinging sixties in Los
Angeles and so they came to an abrupt
ends the ninth of August 8th 1969 the
night the followers of the infamous
Charles Manson visited the house of
pregnant actress Sharon Tate leaving the
town change forever in their bloody wake
Tarantino's story is told through the
lens of fictional washed-up actor Rick
Dalton at his best buddy and stunt
double cliff booth as they find
themselves in the middle of the seismic
events of that night praise was a few
save for Brad Pitt and Leonardo
DiCaprio's amazing on-screen chemistry
and while not every critic was convinced
once upon a time in Hollywood was
generally found to stammers Tarantino's
best work as Lew Thomas of den of geek
wrote Tarantino has created a storming
hangout movie for the ages changing
times captured remarkably by a film in
love with cinema itself I'm Rick Donn
stunt double stunning
yeah you know you're kind of pretty for
a stuntman that's what they tell me
writer-director arias sir made a huge
noise in 2018 with his terrifying debut
hereditary but in 2019 we discovered
that he had just been warming up
midsomer finds troubled couple Danny and
Christian going on a trek to the Swedish
countryside to a remote village the
bizarre happenings there and fold not in
the dead of night but in broad sunny
daylight one of many unusual aspects of
the film which critics singled out for
praise myths OMERS and The Lying themes
also packed a punch as Danny's grief
over a family tragedy opens a door to a
harrowing examination of our ability to
deal with internal struggles salons
Matthew Rosa rose midsummer isn't just a
great horror movie or proof that
director arias sir is a budding author
who likely has a bright future ahead of
him it is also one of the best movies
ever made about living with mental
illness from producer guillermo del toro
and director andre over doll comes a
big-screen adaptation of the beloved
children's book series scary stories to
tell in the dark the film weaves a
series different stories together into a
spooky tale of a group of teenagers who
discover the lost writings of a very
troubled little girl said writings have
a way of leaping right off the page
literally as the book spooky content
start coming menacingly to life over
Dallas no slouch when it comes to
bringing the scarce although in keeping
with its target audience the flick was
found to be more spooky than grisly but
most critics agree that the director had
not an admirable achievement Chicago
readers Andrea Granville wrote if there
ever was a case of a film adaptation
improving on the original source
material this is it and ready or not a
new bride is treated to a murderous game
of hide and seek at the estate of her
allegedly loving husband's family the
flick earned stellar reviews most of
which praised us under lighting themes
of tension between the rich and poor as
well as its deaf to mix of comedy and
jaw-dropping Gore said Rolling Stones
Peter Travers what a decadent blast to
watch a comic takedown of the rich dumb
with the rude energy of a horror
thriller and the courage of its own
manic anti-marriage convictions
lead actress Samara weavings performance
was also singled out for praise early
and often
but the definitive assessment of the
flake was handed down by Alan odd
of the main edge it ready you're nuts
you get a brutal and darkly funny twist
on horror movie tropes you laugh your
cringe and you'll probably do both at
the same time a six seasons two British
period drama Downton Abbey kept
audiences on both sides of the pond
enthralled the show ended in 2015 but
the feature film of the same name picked
up right from where it left off
make no mistake Downton Abbey is
fanservice of the highest order and
while it might have left the uninitiated
puzzled the flick was a welcome gift for
longtime viewers as Matt Zoller states
of Roger Ebert calm wrote the three and
a half star rating at the top of this
review is not for people who don't like
Downton Abbey I've never seen it or grew
tired of watching it the rating is for
diehards the kinds of viewers who will I
suspect turn this movie into an
unexpected smash lo and behold he was
right illustrating that Downton Abbey
knew its audience better than perhaps
any film of 2019 this is good I thought
something else was planned but it is
excellent so well done to old Corby 2019
most ambitious sci-fi drama saw an
astronaut journeying to the edge of the
universe to find his missing father if
I'd asked true and fumbled its weighty
premise even the presence of Brad Pitt's
one of Hollywood's most bankable stars
might not have saved it fortunately
co-writer and director James gray
largely stuck the landing app it
assisted with a performance that ranks
among the best in his career and
hornaday of the Washington Post praised
Pitts performance while applying that
the visually impressive films greatest
strengths line its themes she wrote it's
a terrific ride yes but also a
provocative meditation of masculinity
the things we choose to cherish or
squander and other eternal verities of
life that swell and resolved while our
little blue marble continues to spin the
great Leonard Maltin are even more
praised right saying James Gray is one
of our foremost and most original
filmmakers we already knew that Brad
Pitt is an exceptional leading man but
this performance furnishes a reputation
the film is among this year's very best
you probably knew right off the bat
swear the good boys would be your cup of
tea or more accurately your kind of
cheap beer still for viewers who found
the idea of a trio of foul-mouthed
between boys stumbling to a series of
inappropriate situations to be a formula
fell arity the flick delivered big time
good boys young leaves were roundly
praised for their charming perform
this in a movie that served up a
surprising amount of warmth alongside
it's crass comedic Sensibility
Chicago Sun Times critic and former
Roger Ebert cohort Richard Roeper wrote
even the most hard-core jokes of a
good-natured and even sweet larger
context for all its wacky gross-out
Shakya humor good boys has a lots of
hearts it's not a good fern his dad is
two duis and a specific train for work
that's a good burn it seems like only a
matter of time before the charismatic
and hilarious Jillian Bell achieves
major stardom
if the universe is a just place Britney
runs a marathon will be the final stop
before that destination the dramedy
failed to set the box office on fire but
it has all the makings of a future cult
classic
it says sometimes hysterical sometimes
heartfelt examination of what it takes
to achieve true self-improvement it's
also anchored by a lead performance
which suggests that this was a role
Bella been waiting for all her life as
Michael Phillips of the Chicago Tribune
puts it the movie succeeds because Belle
succeeds it's gratifying to see a
so-called character actress trip
reliably deadly comic timing loosen up
stretch out and learn what it means to
carry a movie the curse of the farewell
won't be terribly well known to American
audiences with one glaring exception
aquafina the rapper turned actress who
has had perhaps a hotter two-year run
than anyone in Hollywood the drama D
deals with a large Chinese family who
throw together a wedding as an excuse to
get together when they discovered that
their grandmother was dying
writer-director Lulu Wang puts a star
through a dramatic and comedic paces in
service of a film that deathly pulls off
a trick which is slowly starting to
become more common in Hollywood selling
a universally relatable story from a
specific cultural point of view the
farewell received near universal praise
with one common caveats bring your
tissues
total films Jamie Graham said it's a
film about family with all its frets and
foibles fondness and fidelity
it is heartfelt and beautifully observed
so while everyone on screen is doing
their utmost to hold back tears yours
will come unchecked
hustler stars Jennifer Lopez of the
veteran stripper who trains her peers in
the finer points of her site job
drugging and ripping off wealthy clients
taking place against the backdrop of the
2008 financial collapse the film was
hailed for its smart writing and
directing and the amazing chemistry of
its cast in KU Kang of Slate called
hustle
an immediate entrant into the pantheon
of female friendship movies and a pretty
much perfect film many critics noted
that those expecting a pandering empty
exercise would be disappointed
as film bunkers Kurian curved roads what
could have been a film weighed down by
its own agenda presented its main
characters as living breathing complex
individuals shying away from the empty
girl power rhetoric that a lot of
Hollywood features try to feed the
masses as feminism furthermore it was
entertaining and a pleasure to watch the
lights house is a black-and-white period
piece in which two lights house
operators slowly lose their minds while
stationed on an isolated island the film
ended up being a lot more entertaining
than that sounds thanks in large part to
the committed performances of athletes
Robert Pattinson and Willem Dafoe Adam
Graham of Detroit News drew an
interesting comparison in his assessment
of the film he said the lighthouse is a
starkly gorgeous black and white Ted
trip that is like staring into a
blinding light you're hypnotized you
can't look away and your eyes won't be
the same after strike you get Winslow's
much have been written about the
Irishman well before his release because
the Netflix film carries a pedigree
unlike any other it's a late career work
for Martin Scorsese perhaps the greatest
living film director which stars his
longtime accomplices Robert DeNiro and
Joe Pesci it's also got ALPA Chino with
whom Scorsese had never worked
previously finally the film is based on
the biography of union leader Frank
Sheeran who is purported to have had mob
ties and may have even killed Jimmy
Hoffa critics welcomed it as an absolute
tour de force one of Scorsese's best
efforts at a filmography full of
masterpieces Rolling Stones Peter
Travers Rhodes with the Irishman
America's greatest living director
creates his late career masterpiece a
deeply felt addition that vibe released
sums up every landmark in his crime
cinema arsenal veteran director James
Mangold gave us a superhero movie and
like any other with 2017 slogan and for
his next trick he decided to smoothly
shift gears into a period piece drama
about race cars on the men who drive
them with Ford vs. Ferrari Madden Gould
had the added bonus of working with Matt
Damon and Christian Bale two acting
masters and viewing their characters
with layers of emotional complexity the
resulting flick is a rousing historical
crowd-pleaser with critics mostly
agreeing that the moon
he has every bit the well-oiled machine
that one would expect San Diego readers
Matthew Laconia wrote Mangold indulges
himself with this tale of American
manhood but he knows he can afford it
he's got Bourne and Batman as brilliant
brawling vest Birds more than a few
critics opined that the film was a touch
too long but that the amazing chemistry
between Damon and Bale carries it
through his more draggy stretches its
overall reception was best summarized by
Quad City times than the cook who
succinctly wrote Ford vs. Ferrari is a
great ride some Hanks appearing as Fred
Rogers is about the most spot-on piece
of casting anyone could have ever hoped
for and the biopic a beautiful day in
the neighborhood makes good on that
potential at a time and we could all use
a bit more of the values that Roger
espoused the movie isn't content just to
illustrate the late children's show
hosts dedication to set values instead
it shows how those values inspired
everyone around him as Roger Ebert combs
Monica Castillo wrote the movie isn't so
much a biopic as it is a way to look at
the way mr. Rogers affected generations
of children young and grown if its
current sir seems too simple it's likely
because that's how many people saw him
and complicated and confined to his
on-screen persona that's the lasting
power of Mister Rogers writer director
Brian Johnson weld fans with knives else
his inspired tribute Agatha Christie
style whodunits with an all-star cast
including Chris Evans Daniel Craig Jamie
Lee Curtis and Michael Shannon the flick
won over critics with his crackerjack
writing and playfully devious vibe
eugene weeklies molly Templeton set off
the film Johnson's vision translates a
love for classic murder mysteries into a
kaleidoscopic ensemble piece that twists
and spins using the structure and tropes
of mystery and comedy to expose the
endless ways humans justify being
absolutely rotten to each other
real-life whistleblowers have long
provided fodder for excellent cinematic
dramatizations for more the president's
mentor Michael Clayton the Mark Ruffalo
vehicle dark waters full squarely into
that tradition telling the story of
Robert bilious an attorney whose 20-year
long pursuit of chemical corporation
DuPont upended his life in ways few
could imagine
directed by Oscar nominee Todd Haynes
the film received critical kudos for
spilling and entertaining yarn from what
could have been the ingredients for a
plodding procedure wall there was also
plenty of praise for Ruffalo's
performance which conclusively proves
that the actor is more than just a Hulk
Richard Roeper of the Chicago sun-times
wrote Ruffalo is a master at playing a
certain type of earnest character who
often wears a quizzical expression not
pokers he's slow on the uptake but
because he's a smartest person in the
room and he has questions no one else
has even thought to ask the film's true
power was laid out nicely by Dominic
Griffin of spectrum culture dark waters
are special because it's not about
dramatically building to an inevitable
victory but about the importance of
fighting every day anyway knowing such a
conclusion may never come with any
literary work that has been adapted as
many times as Louisa May Alcott's Little
Women is always worth asking if one more
is really necessary as illustrated by
the 2019 adaptation the answer is yes
especially when an adaptation is written
and directed by Greta Gerwig the
filmmaker behind the oscar-nominated
2017 film Lady Bird working with an
all-star cast including the likes of
Saoirse Ronan Emma Watson Florence Pugh
Laura Dern and Meryl Streep Gerwig
delivered a timeless open hearted
adaptation that delighted longtime fans
of the book and new audiences alike Lisa
Johnson Mandel of at home in Hollywood
singled out for the latest telling
differs from all the rest right saying
little women should be promoted with
director Greta Gerwig name in the title
her colorful warm and creative touch is
what sets her apart from so many
versions of the story and so many other
kriti filings and tiresome films of the
day it's simply a joy to watch the joy
was definitely contagious
according to cinema woods Joel may word
it's a warm hug of a film go away
clearly loves every one of these
characters and such love flows from the
screen to the audience with generosity
and grace the brothers Josh and Brady
safty turned in one of 2019 specced
isn't terribly surprising
their previous feature was he underrated
good time a harrowing thriller which
conclusively proved that star Robert
Pattinson
is a real deal as an actor the surprise
in uncut gems as Adam Sandler who stars
as a gambling addict did jewelry store
owner Howard Ratner critics were simply
mesmerized by his performance which has
been greeted by nearly universal acclaim
the sun-times Richard Roeper called the
Fleck
uncut gems is one of the most authentic
deep dives into the world of the
gambling addict ever put some film Adam
Sandler's performance as a New York
jeweler with a variety of Brosius
appetites ranks right up there with the
works of Steve McQueen in the Cincinnati
kid Edward Norton a Matt Damon
roundest George Segal and Elliott Gould
in California splits and James Caan in
the gambler
virtually all reviewers were stunned by
sunless work and the supporting cast
which included the likes of Lockheed
Stanfield Kevin Garnett's and idina
menzel were no slouches either Rob Dean
of daily grindhouse arguably summed it
up best uncut gems as the best panic
attack you'll have all year a brilliant
character study an engaging story of
various lowlifes and one of the best
films of 2019 this is me this is how I
win when Joker was announced it was easy
to feel the flick was even going to be a
disaster or a masterpiece
once the trailers were released it
quickly became clear that the flick
would be his homage to gritty seventies
character studies in general and to the
works of Martin Scorsese in particular
director Todd Phillips ace-in-the-hole
though or says sour keen Phoenix and
Phillips diligently crafted an intense
portrait of a very disturbed man one
which challenged the notion of what a
comic book movie could be Joker not only
became the first r-rated film to gross
over a billion dollars worldwide but it
received 11 Academy Award nominations
more than any other 2019 movie it may
have divided critics but not so much
audiences who by and large saw the film
for what it was a masterclass in film
studies with near-flawless acting
direction and editing and the greatest
pure character study that's been put to
film in decades check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos buy your favorite movies
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and to the bowel so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]